my colleague honor argon chu on the nlts
conductor
which you could think of as a first step
towards
proving the quantum pcb conjecture
so we've known for quite a while that
calculating the lowest eigenvalue
or the ground energy of a local
hamiltonian to
a logarithmic number of bits of
precision is a qma complete
good morning everyone i'm wondering if
jin may is going to be presenting
from in person from simon's institute
hi can you hear me right
i i he already started actually so he's
here
i wonder if my there's no video oh no i
can't hear you
okay let's try this again
the video is on you yeah yeah all right
now
all um i think i'll just continue then
so right so we've known that the
local hamiltonian problem to uh
a logarithmic number of bits is complete
and qma of course
being the non-deterministic
version of quantum computation and at
the same time
we've also known from the celebrated pcp
theorem
that the estimation problem is actually
just as hard
in the case of classical hamiltonians
when
you're just trying to get the first
couple bits uh and this in the
classical local hematites the analog
would be mp completeness
so it begs the question that sort of
just sits there as the mate one of the
big outstanding questions in
quantum complexity theory is is
non-deterministic quantum computation
as hard to solve approximately as it is
to solve exactly
um or in a very specific form
what's the complexity of approximating
the
energy of a local hamiltonian the ground
energy
well unfortunately we don't know this
problem
but we can try to make some progress in
towards
figuring out the complexity of this
question
so let's start off with something very
basic
which is to say that if we believe that
np
is separate from qma then
if this quantum pcb conjecture was to be
true
we would hope to say that approximating
the energy
is harder than np
one way of saying that is that
any classical proof that the
uh for energy approximation should
require super polynomial length or it
should not be in empty
the proof should be very long
but that's going to be really hard to do
because that would also
imply just that np was separate from qma
so
let's back up a little bit even more and
try to say
a simpler goal which is that all
classical proofs of a very specific form
are going to require super polynomial
length and this will give us an
advantage at least it's starting to get
some handling as to what makes
qma hard well you know what gives it
that the edge over classical proofs
so we noticed one simple phenomenon that
if you have a local hamiltonian h
you can calculate in polynomial time the
energy of a state
if that state is the output of a
constant depth quantum circuit
um and when we say polynomial time i'm
here i mean for a classical computer so
a classical computer in polynomial time
can calculate the energy of a state
that's the output of a constant
quantum circuit so
that likes to say that if you had a
constant depth state
of low energy then that in itself would
be an
np proof of low energy because someone
could give you the description of the
circuit that produces the state
that's a classical description and then
you could use this statement
above to just check the energy and check
there is sufficiently more
so these constant of states can
potentially be certificates
of low energy they may not be
certificates of the lowest energy
but they could certainly be certificates
of low energy
so this leads to the very simple
conjecture deposited no low energy
trivial states conjecture or the nlps
conjecture
that there should exist hamiltonians
with
no low energy constant depth states as
in
there is no classical certificate that
comes in the form of a
circuit description that would certify
that the energy of this hamiltonian was
sufficiently low
another way of saying this is you're
trying to prove a lower bound on the
complexity of all low energy
states so to get this a little deeper
now let's try to introduce a little more
technicality to these kind of
open-ended loose statements and let's
formally state what we're talking about
so the quantum pcb conjecture says if
you have a hamiltonian system that acts
on say
n qubits where the hamiltonian terms are
going to be necessarily local
so i mean that in two different ways i
mean that each qubit is acted on by only
a finite
a constant number of hamiltonian terms
and each hamiltonian term
can be described by its action on only a
constant number of qubits
then the question of calculating this
energy
has the following complexity so given if
you're asked given the description of
the hamiltonian classically as an object
how hard is it to approximate the energy
up to some accuracy
and we know that the approximate energy
to inverse polynomial one over
n squared that's q omega certainly
and the quantum pcb conjecture is
asserting that that's also qmi hard
when you increase this approximation
factor a lot
to a linear fraction
the lts conjecture then you could write
in the following very specific format
that let's say we define the circuit
complexity of the state
as the minimum depth circuit required to
generate
that state so by here i mean that there
is a circuit
the gates are any two cubic unitaries
they don't need to be geometrically
local
and if you trace out some of the wires
at the end of the day the state that
remains is your
state then the nlts conjecture
formally says that we need to have a
family of local hamiltonians
such that every state of low energy
every state
of energy below epsilon and
these states cannot be described by
circuits of constant depth
or in other words saying that the
circuit complexity of these states has
to be super cost
pictorially you could sort of imagine
that the circuit complexity of
states sort of drops as we relax the
energy requirement
and it says that as long as the
energy is below some threshold so
epsilon threshold the circuit complexity
is certainly super constant
so let's just elucidate the implication
that we had stated
um kind of uh casually in
in a more direct manner so let's put
these two
powerful conjectures together so imagine
you had a
quantum pcp statement that said
something like
given a local hamiltonian h and
you're asked if the minimum energy is
either zero or bigger than
ten percent and and to say that was qmi
hard
and you were assumed that nlts was false
so it said for every epsilon and every
local hamiltonian
there was a state of constant circuit
complexity
that certified that the energy was at
least less than epsilon n
and so it just said that every if n lts
is false it says that every local
hamiltonian
is going to have a state of low depth
with low energy
so if we put these two together we're
going to find a contradiction we're
mainly going to find that
np has to equal q of a
so the way that kind of goes is imagine
you had a qma proof
that the minimum energy is zero
and that qma proof basically looks like
a state row
such that trace h rho is actually zero
but instead since we're assuming that
nlts is false
we know there is a state of constant
circuit complexity sigma
such that the energy of sigma is going
to be
less than 1 over 20 n so say 5
and what we can say is let u be the
defining circuit
for the state sigma because it has low
circuit complexity
and the claim is that the description of
you
is all you need as a certificate that
the hamiltonian had a low
was low energy and that description of
the circuit you is a classical witness
so what do you have to just check you
have to check that if the minimum energy
was actually zero
of the hamiltonian problem then you can
just classically check the trace of h
sigma
is less than one over 20 n but if the
minimum energy
of the hamiltonian was larger was larger
than 1 over 10 n
then no matter what classical
description you give you're just going
to get some state
and necessarily that means that the
energy of that state is bigger than 1
over 20 m
so what you get is that if you're trying
to approximate
the energy of a hamiltonian to just
constant factors
and nlts was false then you would get
that qma equals mp
and this is crucially because the depth
of the
of you that is the circuit constructing
the witness
is constant
so if we're going out there and we're
trying to prove
quantum pcp a first step a very
reasonable first step is to try to prove
this nlts
to show that at least this very simple
form of classical proofs
cannot be used you know to verify the
energy of hamiltonians approximately
and in doing so what we're going to need
to do
is we're going to need to sort of
provide circuit lower bounds for all the
low energy states
of some hamiltonians
so let's dive into that exact question
which is we need techniques
for proving the circuit depth lower
bounds
for hamiltonians and ideally we want to
do this without any computational
assumptions so
the first idea we have for proving
circuit lower bounds
is to use information propagation so if
you have a load-backed circuit
interestingly enough you have this
beautiful result that the information
propagates
not too far because the circuit is low
depth
so let's describe this in a following
manner let's say we have a circuit u
and we identify an input y or i
our input cubed i and we define the
light cone
li as all the output qubits
that could be informationally related to
the input qubit i
through this circuit and the idea is
that because the
circuit is low depth the size of this
light cone
is bounded it's at most two to the depth
of the circuit
so in the case of small constant depth
circuits the light cone is only a
constant factor bigger than the input
cubit itself
and we have this very interesting
property
when we talk about low depth circuits
that if i want to know
the value of the i qubit so if i trace
out
all but the if cubit of the state row
after it's rotated by the unitary u this
is equivalent to first just looking at
the reduced state of row
on that light cone and then rotating
that
so there's a very nice simple proof of
this so you can say
you can show that for any operator a uh
i can rewrite this trace formalism of
the measurement of operator a on the i
cubit
as trace ua u dagger row
and pictorially this looks something
like this here's the operator a
it's sandwiched between the circuit u
and u dagger and rho sits on the outside
but notice that a lot of the gates are
right across
with their complement gate so you can
just start to cancel them out because
they're
they're unitary gates and they cancel
with their
component and you get this simplified
picture that all that's really left
is the circuit u acting only on the
light cone
of that wire and then you're left with
row
so what that means is that you can
rewrite this as trace of ua
you'd have a row on the light cone
and since this is true for any operator
a it tells you exactly the statement in
green that the
value of the i fit only depends on its
like
the second powerful property we're going
to need is this notion of global
entanglement
which is a uniquely quantum property
that you can have which is that if you
have
two states psi and psi prime
such that on small regions they look the
same
so in every small region these two
states look the same
then you can actually show that psi
cannot be generated by a circuit of
depth less than log p
so an example state just to keep in mind
for global entanglement
is the cat state that would be the all
zero state plus the all one states
this state is indistinguishable from the
cat minus
state where instead it's all zeros minus
all ones
because on any size region other than
all
the qubits itself this just looks like a
maximally mixed state between all zeros
and all ones
and so how do you sort of show this step
well you use the previous information
bound
which is let's assume that psi was
generated by a low depth circuit u
of dep some t less than log d
okay then what you get is that the size
of any light cone is at most two to the
t and that's upper bounded by d
so then we start off by saying okay if i
rotate psi
by u i'm just going to get back all
zeroes
so that gives me that first equality
and then i use this property that the
information
only depends on the light cone just
switch side for psi
on that light cone and now i just
noticed that oh
the psi on the light cone the light cone
is really small
so it's exactly equal to psi prime of
the light cone
and so i get the next equality and then
i put one more back together to bring me
back
to get that the i qubit of rotated
psi prime is exactly zero zero
and then what that tells you is that psi
prime is going to overall look like
0 0 when rotated which gives you the psi
prime is equal to psi
and therefore you have a contradiction
so it's a simple proof
that if you have this global
entanglement property you inherently
have at least some circuit lower bound
so a question then is you know how can
we create
states that have global entanglement for
all the low energy states
so a good idea might be to start with
code states
for quantum error correction so
they are truly a fruitful source of
global entanglement
because you can show that every code
state of
an nkd code has the same marginals
so the reduced density matrix on small
regions is
exactly the same for all the code states
and there's a two different proofs i
know of this the first one you can show
it follows directly from the canila
phlom conditions but i don't think that
one's really intuitive
but the the intuitive proof that i think
about is that if the region is
correctable
then i can recover the state back
from the rest of the space so that means
that psi is recoverable
from psi on minus r on everything but
the region r
and therefore if psi r
the density matrix of psi on that small
region
did depend on psi then this violates no
cloning
because now you have the completely
recovered state side
plus something which is partially
correlated with it in general
so note and then no information in this
context exactly means that those
that the reduced density matrix on that
small region must be a complete
invariant
it cannot depend on what stated original
started with and that's why you get this
property
so immediately from this property that
codes have
uh the same marginals you necessarily
see that codes
are a form of global entanglement
as long as the distance is good and if
you have the codes
have uh you know global entanglement
using the previous steps we have
we immediately get that every code state
of a code
that requires some circuit depth that's
circuit depth scales like log
sorry that should say log d excuse me um
and uh in general these uh you know it's
like a
good code b will be like maybe square
root n or polynomial and n so
that gives you log n up to constant
factors
now the difficulty inherently is how do
we take this property of global
entanglement
that exists at least for the code states
the zero energy states if this error
correct
and extend it to the states of low
energy with respect to the code
um so an ideal idea right would be that
if we
could take any low energy state with
respect to this code
and we could create that sort of
imposter state
the state that you know mimics it on all
the local marginals but it's
different from that state then certainly
you know we would have a
we'd have a proof for the circuit
complexity
that turns out to be sort of hard but
what we can show through this result
of myself and anuraganshu from last year
is that if you have a code
and you can prove a circuit lower bound
on all the states of low energy and the
circuit
lower bound that we get uh scales like
order minimum of log n and log one over
epsilon
so when epsilon is a constant factor
this gives a constant
depth lower bound on the circuit
complexity what we'd really like to say
for the nlps result is a circuit lower
bound that's independent
of epsilon and we unfortunately are not
able to achieve this but we are able to
give the first
circuit depth lower bound for all states
of low energy
and in particular if you think of
epsilon as any
function that scales uh
inversely with n then this does indeed
uh give you a super constant lower bound
that's to the complexity
quick question here if i h just for
clarification
what hamiltonian do you assume here so
that there's a relationship between a
cold state and energy oh uh yeah it's
the hamiltonian that defines the code
so in this case it's going to be um
we're going to just talk about an ldpc
stabilizer code
and it's precisely the hamiltonian
defined by taking
each check and converting it into a
projector
great thank you and
the sort of the proof idea is that
while we don't know a proof that every
low energy state satisfies
global entanglement we can't necessarily
find the imposter
we're going to show that we can find
some approximate imposters
states that mimic all the small
marginals
approximately and in fact we can show
that for error correcting codes
not only can we find a imposter that
mimics the marginals
but you can actually find many such
imposters and you're going to use the
property that we can find many such
imposters
along with the fact that each of these
imposters is an approximate imposter
to indeed uh show a lower bound as to
the circuit complexity
um so perhaps i should
pause here for a second see if there are
any questions
that sufficiently confuse everyone or
not
there is a question in the q a i'll read
it up
did your version of nlts assume that the
circuits are spatially local
if not in a non-local circuit the
litecoin argument doesn't give you much
does it um no so the assumption actually
is that the circuits are non-local
that's why we assume that the
size of light cone scales like two to
the t if the circuit was assumed to be
geometrically local
instead of the size of light cone being
two to the t
let's say it's 2d it would scale more
like two times t
right so you could actually get much so
the same results can be used
to prove geometric circuit lower bounds
and you'll actually get much much
tighter
geometric circuit lower bounds as a
consequence
i think you have to be a little careful
because if you start to assume that the
hamiltonians let's say are not constant
locality
then you can get very simple circuit
lower bounds just
based on the fact that if a hamiltonian
is
k local there's at least a circuit lower
bound of k
automatically um this is just good that
you could imagine that hamiltonian is
just the projector into a really random
state
in a circular bound so you have to be a
little careful as to
how you define it for um
hamiltonian with non-constant
so um the statement we had
on the previous slide of a circuit lower
bound is not
it applies to code that we actually know
exists
today and we can actually get very nice
lower bounds so one example is
the t-lex z-more hyper graph product
code for which we know of a linear rate
and a distance which is actually square
root n
and another code that it does apply to
very interestingly is the puncture
torque code
where we assume the punctured charcoal
has a lot of poles
n to the one minus delta holes here the
rate is not linear but it's almost
linear
and uh the distance uh is like scales
like n to the
delta and here you get that uh
a circuit lower bound on all states
of energy n to the one minus two delta
of uh delta log n so if you think of
delta as a constant
this says for like all states of energy
n to the
point 99 or so the circuit complexity of
the scale is at least like log n
what's probably incredibly interesting
is that this torah code
the punctuator code it's the two
dimensional code right it just sits on
the torus
and yet it displays this sort of form of
robust entanglement that we don't
we didn't really previously expect would
exist in low dimensions
okay to sort of start proving
the statement for low energy states
maybe it's helpful to first think about
sort of what do low energy states look
like
for a hamiltonian so if we imagine this
big ball
here is all the states of truly low
energy let's see what it contains
well in the beginning it certainly is
going to contain all the code space
those have energy zero right another
option
is that it contains states which are
just l1 perturbations i start with the
code state
and i just shift it somewhere in the in
the space
by epsilon and what i get is that this
perturbation
you know uh doesn't change the energy
too much because it's just a very small
perturbation
um and you could even generalize that to
say
that it just states that every
hamiltonian
term associated the energy of each of
those
doesn't scale too badly and you can
contrast this with some notion of low
error states
which is you take the code state and
you change it up to on epsilon n qubits
you just completely change it do
whatever you want to a constant
fraction of the qubits but you don't
touch the rest
right and this lower state was actually
an interesting regime that was initially
studied as part of this problem
by myself henry you and umeshwazarani
and also
aaron harrow and leo eldar
and you can also generalize this to a
notion of something i call combinatorial
states
but the idea is that there is a very
vast and diverse
zoo of states in particular the states
that you get by
you know rotating by a small
perturbation those could
really be affecting all the qubits you
could be physically changing all the
qubits
while the lower states you know only act
on a very discrete set of cubits it's
sort of
like at the very forefront there's at
least two different types of errors we
need to sort of handle
um and so that perspective is sort of
nice in using
and it's particularly interesting
actually that these bounds exist for
error correcting codes
because you would think that an error
correcting code would be
quite designed would be really good at
protect against like these low errors
states right protecting as
discrete errors in a certain number of
qubits what's
what's sort of interesting is that we
can actually provide
a lower bound for all these types of
states including these
small ball perturbations
so let's start with that let's start
with trying to see
how to prove a circuit lower bound for
these small perturbations
and let's and we'll see that actually
proving the
problem in this restricted case provides
us basically all the insight we need to
generalize this to all low energy states
so the way to start this is let's just
say that we have some state psi
which is some distance delta from the
code
and we just ask what is the circuit
lower bound of psi
and by the result i said previously we
know that
for any code state that's at least log d
um and for simplicity right now let's
just assume
that psi is a pure state and that the
circuit generating psi
is going to be a circuit without
incidents these these assumptions are
not necessary but it'll
simplify the proof for the purpose of
this talk
and here's the theorem we're going to
show is we're going to show that as long
as the distance
scales as square root of d delta sorry
is less
than the rate k over n
then for any state that is that distance
we actually can
recover the same lower bound of the
constant factors of log d
okay so here's what we're going to do
we're going to do the complete proof of
this statement
i'm not going to skip anything every
step of this should be answered
so here's how we start we're going to
say psi is that state again
and i'm going to introduce a new state
i'm going to call them theta and theta
is going to be the encoded maxillary
mixed state
so one way to think about that is that
the code space is a
you know it's a k-qubit subspace the
whole
hilbert space and this is just the
maximally mixed state over that k
cubit pillar space
and now let's take a small region
r which we believe to be uh correctable
so it's a region of size less than d
and we're going to notice the following
property that the marginals of psi
are pretty good approximation on the
marginals of theta
there's two steps one is just the
distance psi is close to row
and then row is a code word so by the
local indistinguishability
property that we showed row and theta
have the exact same marginals
okay and now let's assume something
that's going to yield our contradiction
so let's assume that psi was built by a
low depth circuit so there's a circuit u
and the depth of that circuit was small
it's smaller than such that 2 to the t
is less than d so what we get
immediately is the statement in magenta
that if i rotate that state psi by the
unitary u i get back to the all zero
state
which in particular means cube it by
cubit
the rotated psi looks like zero
and now we're going to put that together
just like we did a couple slides ago in
a very similar equation
let's break it down so the first
equality on the very left side that's
just copying
from uh the previous time then the
the next the green equality we see there
is i'm saying that
i can restrict psi to the light cone
right the same sort of trick i'd
involved
a couple steps ago i'm just now going to
say i'm going to restrict side to the
like cone
and now i get this approximation factor
right i get an approximation factor that
came from the
fact that psi uh on small regions
approximates theta on small regions
and then i put it back together to get
that the
rotated qubit of theta
looks a lot like zero right
looking at the whole equation left to
right i just get that the rotated
cubit of theta looks a lot like zero in
particular it says something very
interesting
that the entropy of that
rotated cubit of theta is cubit by qubit
the entropy of that qubit
is at most square root delta this is
just from the fact that it's really
close to a pure state
right so what does that tell me though
is now i can add up the entropy
i first noticed that the maximally mixed
state because it's the maximum mixed
state over this k-qubit subspace
it has entropy at least k right
but a trivial bound for the entropy of a
state
is the entropy of each of the qubits one
after another
i can just add up the entropy cubit by
qubit and now i get this following fact
that i get that k
must be less than square root of delta
times n
but that was precisely the assumption we
you know
made the in the opposite direction so
therefore we get our contradiction
and the only assumption we've made was
that psi came from a
load up circuit and that will complete
our proof
so let's pause for a second and see
really how similar this was
to the proof that code states have
a high circuit complexity all we did
differently is we noticed that we
couldn't necessarily find an imposter
for psi but we could definitely find an
approximate imposter
right using this equation one that psi
looks fairly close to the maximum
mixtape on
theta but what this actually tells me
though
is that not only did i find one imposter
but i found
a lot of imposters because theta was
this maximally mixed state over the code
i found that psi was really uh had a lot
of impostors
and i used that in the fact that there
were many approximate imposters
um to put it together to get an uh
entropy contradiction
this provides a technique for lower
bounding all the low distance states
so now now that we have a bound for low
distance states
we're going to take this bound and we're
going to lift it to bounding all the low
energy states
and the way we're going to do this is
we're just going to notice a very nice
property
that in the case of ldpc stabilizer
codes
where all the checks are tensor products
of a few paulies
you get that not only does the code
space which is defined as the
um set of
vectors that satisfy all the checks but
also every
eigenspace of this code has this local
indistinguishability property
the marginals are the same and this is a
very
easy fact to prove just coming from the
kaniloflam conditions
and then we can use this sort of at a
very high level
to argue a circuit lower bound for all
low energy states by first breaking them
up
according to the eigenspace and then
eigenspace by eigenspace
arguing a circuit lower bound this is
the sort of a really meaty technical
argument so we're going to skip it for
now
and that is sort of what gives us this
main technical theorem
that i had alluded to earlier
okay so if given this
almost nlts conjecture that anurag and i
had proven
maybe the right thing to do is look back
and say you know what does this actually
tell me about quantum pcp
well here's what we kind of hoped for
from quantum pcp was that if
the nlts theorem was false then we knew
that quantum pcp was false because we
just showed it was a necessary condition
unfortunately or fortunately however you
want to look at it we were able to show
that nlts is
probably true considering that we can
prove these sort of lower bounds
very closely there's you know probably a
few things left uh
some eyes to dot and some t's to cross
um and so the hope was that this
construction of a family of nlts
hamiltonians
you know it should have given us some
insight into how to create
quantum pcp hamiltonians unfortunately
so we saw that the this property of nlts
is sort of
general right it's actually somehow a
general property of quantum era
correction
and didn't really require any strong
assumptions as to
the type of code or any serious strong
properties of them
and so you might you know
condescendingly say okay at first glance
you know can you really learn anything i
mean even more the
the the hamiltonians that we were able
to prove stuff about were stabilizer
codes
and we know stabilizer codes are
clifford states which means that they
are
sort of classically similar by other
means and i would say that's a very
fair point and in fact what you might
want to say is you need to now move
towards lower bounding against all forms
of poly size classical proofs and in
particular because you're able to show
that
clifford states had circuit lower bounds
you might want to say let's try this
some no low energy clifford states
conjecture
which is to construct a hamiltonian
family with no low energy clifford
states
that might be a very reasonable next
question and then all these techniques
which i discussed kind of
maybe fall out the window and we don't
know what to do next
and you might even say even further more
condescendingly
you actually should lower bound any
state with inverse poly overlap with
some low energy state
and in fact we are able to do this in
the case of um
the lower bounds from the result from
monorag and i but
we would have to say this at least in
the clifford setting as well
and maybe these techniques would involve
insights behind stabilizer codes and
error correction
because now you're trying to really
combine two different challenging things
starting to take something about
hamiltonians which are non-clifford
and you know prove some really
interesting lower balance
now this leads to maybe a more pcp
inspired technique for proving lower
bounds
and this comes from this very simple
idea
that if we had a local hamiltonian h
we could create a transformation to
produce a new hamiltonian g
uh which is just like negative a
power of h and what you can easily show
is that this hamiltonian
g at least the the the promise gap of
the hamiltonian g
increases by a factor p relative to the
promise gap of h just by doing this sort
of amplification technique
that is a core part of the classical pcp
conjecture
and one thing we actually are able to
show is that this this amplification
technique
not only amplifies the lowest uh
eigenvalue
as was shown in the pcp proofs and then
also a result
for the quantum version but it actually
amplifies
uh it's solid against all low depth
states
so you can show that if a state has uh
you know
low energy with respect to h its energy
and its low depth its energy with g
increases by a factor of p
um but there's a fundamental issue in
this
technique that uh that is rectified in
the classical
pcp theorem is that that once you start
off with h and you do this amplification
the new hamiltonian g
is no longer local and you're going to
need some sort of locality reduction and
this is the part that's
sort of missing and maybe this
is something we need to work on but it
should be known that in general this is
false
and unfortunately it's false and due to
the exact properties of global
entanglement that we had discussed
earlier the two states can look the same
in all marginals
but they could be very different so
i know that doesn't really settle
anything but i don't think we should
really be
settling anything right now because the
world is still quite open in this manner
there's some more smaller open questions
here
relating to technical details of the
nlts conjecture of
myself and honorag but i i think on the
interest of time i'll open up to any
questions from the audience about
any aspect
hey questions uh i don't know if i'm
host or not but umash sent me a message
around two in the morning asking me to
help
and uh so i'm i'm willing to ask a
question if nobody else has one
oh please go ahead sir sivaric
hi jimmy can you hear me yeah
okay so thanks for the lovely talk um i
want to just play devil's advocate for a
moment and just ask a very naive
question right like
if your goal is to prove something like
quantum pcp right
it would seem to me that you know trying
to prove explicit circuit lower bounds
on all low energy states
i mean that seems like a very very
difficult way to go
about proving quantum pcp right because
it almost seems like it would separate
np from qma right you're proving that
there literally
is no good proof classically
uh not quite right because not all
classical proofs
will look like load up quantum circuits
right sure like for example
um you could always show that there was
a low energy clifford state and that's
going to be uh
and you could just you know um provide
me the stabilizer
stabilizer description of that state and
you know that's certainly sufficient
but that doesn't look like something
that comes from a load up circuit in the
slightest
sure but i mean either way i mean you're
you're assuming some form of unzots and
you're trying to prove some sort of
explicit lower bound right that's that's
literally unconditionally separating
like what's possible classically versus
quantumly
and that seems like a very difficult
thing to do in the context of separating
complexity classes right
yeah yeah so so that was it that's just
my
my comment it's just very naively that's
something that just occurs to me
yeah i mean and this was sort of the
hope right was the hope was that somehow
trying to find this inherent
uh property that a hamiltonian with
circuit lower bounds for all the low
energy states would
sort of guide you towards what a quantum
pcp hamiltonian would look like
but yeah it seems like it's a more
generic property than we thought so
it opens up the myriad of questions in
that sense
[Music]
okay thank you i think we might
have time for one more question aaron
well i guess along the lines of that
question
it raised the possibility that
like maybe an approach to nlts could
just be looking for some
polynomial time transform like jordan
wigner's or some other kind of transform
that
um you know
state states that we very much think we
can
like basically trying to prove nlcs
while while doing something that would
never work for qpcp
seems like it might be it might be more
promising i don't know if
if you've thought about that beyond like
like stabilizers are one great example
but i wonder if you thought about other
other uh families of states that are
easy but not
constant depth uh
yeah i think that's a pretty good
question i don't really have any other
ideas on techniques for proving lower
bounds so
um that i don't i wouldn't know how to
maybe start with those kind of states
but at the very least constant depth
states are also used as onsites is in
like qaoa so
this says you know maybe they aren't as
descriptive as we thought also so
it has a application in that sense also
oh yeah good point thanks
cool um i actually have a very quick
question where
while maybe leo gets set up and share
screen
um which is um so she made you
had a little aside there where you said
that you would be disregarding circuits
with
uh ancillas but clearly ancillar
grants circuits more power so could you
try having some incis assisted circuits
along the lines aaron just described
oh um sorry uh i should have clarified
the the main theorem at least and the
theorem in the paper
will allow circuits within syllabus it's
just for the purposes of that nice
cute proof it's easier to just make this
statement without the insulas for the
moment um but yeah you can generalize to
circuits within cells
as and even mixed states so
i see it's because of your use of the
information bound and the light cone
the lee robinson bound yeah you extend
to ancilla's by just considering the
purifications
uh and the same thing you're going to
need for anyways considering mixed
states so the the technique you know
sufficiently
solves both of those cases also cool
thank you very much
let's all give and shimmy another hand
[Music]
[Applause]
okay next up we have leo zoe from
harvard and stanford and he'll be
telling us about strong universal
hamiltonian simulators
leo it's all yours